more on this let's bring in Chad with
former DHS acting secretary and America
First policy Institute executive
director Chad I'm rarely shocked by
things but what Jillian just reported
seems to me to just be so beyond the
bail let's get your take on it
well absolutely look there you know when
they recruit a volunteer force uh
Brandon Judd's right there's a crisis
along that border but it really
infuriates me because they're not
actually trying to solve the problem
they're just trying to manage the influx
of individuals coming across that border
and that's fine you we've got to take
care of them you've got to process them
but where are the measures in place that
we're actually trying to solve this so
in two and three months six months from
now we're not in the same place and
that's where this Administration is just
falling asleep they have no plan in
place to actually mitigate this to
actually try to reduce the numbers to
draw this crisis to a close instead they
just continue to manage this throwing
more Personnel whether it's a volunteer
force or it's more border patrol agents
to Simply process these migrants in
every single day at numbers historical
numbers that we've never seen before so
that's what's frustrating to me I know
there are things that works I know there
are ways to mitigate this crisis this
Administration does not seem interested
in doing any of that well they want
people to volunteer here to pick up
garbage along the border
I don't know how you define that job I
don't know where that came from and
we'll see whether or not they can
recruit the way they want to mayorkas is
speaking over the weekend remember when
Kamala Harris said The Border's secure
he said the political cry that the
border is open is music to The
Smuggler's ears because they take that
political rhetoric and they Market it
now the whole idea about the border is
open
um
two years yeah we go to bill malusion
every day there's either a drone in the
sky there's a camera on the ground and I
mean
you know fool yourself if you think the
border is not open
well absolutely I mean this comment by
the secretary is really Beyond The Pale
basically what he's saying is that all
the Americans out there are policy
leaders members of Congress who are
really concerned about this issue and
are actually speaking out on it are
somehow to blame for the crisis that the
Smugglers are slowly listening only
listening uh to these folks and to news
media Fox News and others saying that
the border is open and that's absurd
right uh they know it's open because of
the policies of this Administration they
know it's open because every month they
get hundreds of thousands of individuals
to cross that border every month there's
more and more godaways so the Smugglers
don't need to listen to to political
folks or anyone else talk about the
borders open the reality is the border
is open they know it's open and CBP
interviews folks every single day
migrants every single day and the
migrants are saying the borders open
that's why we're coming here
um and so this this idea and this
comment from the secretary is again
trying to shift blame the blame you know
obviously is on the Biden Administration
the policies are encouraging this surge
nothing else